big liberal city siding with hollywood
over everyday citizens chicago police
are reportedly diverting some officers
away from patrolling neighborhoods so
that they can protect tv and movie sets
instead it's in response to an incident
that happened on a film set where a
suspect lit and threw an unidentified
object nobody was hurt in that
particular incident but the windy city
is already struggling with police
staffing shortages as rampant crime
continues to surge chicago pd is
defending the decision saying this we
work closely with the city's film and
television community to provide safety
and security for the production crews as
well as the communities in which they
film
okay judge i think one of the things is
that there's just not enough police no
there's nothing and they're not law
enforcement and so they're diverting and
you would think that the movie studios
though could hire private security if
they need it that's exactly the point
you know i lived in chicago um for
several years i would go back and forth
um and i love chicago it's a beautiful
city the sad part about it is when they
make a decision that they want to divert
their resources for people who are
coming in to make tvs
tv shows and movies you say to yourself
you know the poor people on the south
side
or those who are now in the loop area
apparently is already is having
dangerously low staffing uh problems as
it relates to the police you have to say
well maybe the tv and movie people ought
to hire their own security that you know
when you think about it the the police
and the businesses pay taxes for police
to defend them and protect them if you
come in from out of state or you come in
to do a movie maybe you should have your
own security so the saddest part let me
just finish on this the saddest part is
47 people were shot in chicago this past
weekend not one person was arrested 47
shot and i believe eight killed eight
dead not one arrest you know what the
judge is saying there about how the
movies should hire their own they're
trying to
but it's probably a city ordinance or
regulation they have to hire off-duty
cops there are no off-duty no you don't
they are trying to hire off-duty cops
for security there's nobody they can
fight them there's nobody to hire and
and nobody wants to come do it
i mean that and so that's the problem i
live in a town in georgia where a lot of
filming is being done and i'll tell you
what
you know what maybe if you can't keep
your people safe you don't get to profit
off the movie industry maybe if you
can't give people the the the least and
like the simplest part of the social
contract which is security if you can't
give people a semblance of that maybe
you don't get to involve yourself in the
movie industry maybe you have other
things you should focus on
maybe an industry of entertainment and
fun and celebrities isn't what the mayor
needs to be catering to because the
people there are in a dire situation i
don't know that's just an idea i'll tell
you what you want to come to noon in
georgia you won't get shot at or
anything but you might have to eat some
fried chicken and cornbread
we have a lot we have a lot of movies
made there yeah and the movie industry
they usually always get tax breaks
anyway right as incentives richard in
order to get there yeah i mean they get
a lot of tax abatements but here's the
thing let's talk about the problems in
chicago and i think they go far beyond
hollywood i think you have a mayor who
can't run the city um and you see it
show up in so many different ways not
only did she prom when she ran she
promised that she was going to fix the
public schools she continues to have
contention with the teachers there but
beyond that under her leadership what
you've seen is on the south and west
side of chicago where you have a lot of
middle class families a lot of upper
class families who have houses there
madam cj walker's original house was
there the first black millionaire um and
and what they're saying is they have a
mistrust for the police and they also
have a mistrust and they have a lack of
confidence in the mayor in the city of
chicago and i i would predict that in
next year in her primary you'll probably
see mayor lori lightfoot unseated
because the people on the south and west
side of the city she ran with a lot of
promises and she hasn't filled any of
them that's why she has it now she wants
to run for office again what do you make
of hollywood getting some what are they
they should stop calling it the windy
city because it's windy no they should
call it people shot in the face city
because you get more people shot in the
face and you get hit by the wind windy
once when i was on michigan avenue
there's a good reason why the police are
on a movie set because people die on
them just ask alec baldwin
but i think it's it's totally normal
to have these people here but it is a
reminder that the film industry in
hollywood and tv will happily denigrate
law enforcement until they need them
right then all of a sudden it's like we
need a guy with a gun on set because our
fans are staring at us and just keep
them away from us and then all of a
sudden like sure i'll take pictures with
the cops i'll pile around i'm a man of
the people and then they'll go on
twitter and crap all over the police but
i think that i have no beef with this if
you actually applied the same concerns
and protections to the community uh what
you do for the filmmakers you do for the
citizens uh if you're if you're
protecting the cast of law and order you
should be providing law and order to
everybody else but i mean if you're
pulling people out of unsafe areas to do
this and that's bs
agreed all right
directly ahead a top democrat panicking
about his party being out of touch as
the midterms get ever closer hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now